Mary Olsen episode 1 Girls Night Out has
over what 1.3 million views now how did
this happen there's so many people that
try to make viral videos and they try
again one these cat videos on yahoo
whatever it is and then here this thing
have happened again well that was in
2008 so it's still a dark ages of the
internet and before we put that up i
don't actually think I'd ever been on
youtube but we made that for a little
contest that SF sketchfest was doing and
put it on youtube and walked away for a
couple months and it had four or five
hundred hits or something and I woke up
one morning and open my email and there
were like 10,000 emails from youtube or
something like that what's going on and
it had been featured on the front page
of all the different YouTube's and
picked up on things and my theory and I
don't know if this is true or not but
when we had first opened the youtube
account I'd done a lot of digging into
recommendations and faq and stuff like
that on youtube and i found an email
address and i wrote to them hey we're
comedians we made this thing you know
we'd love to be featured i don't know if
that actually got to someone or if they
just came up across it organically but
that's my theory I've never seen that
email address again I wouldn't know how
to find it I don't know if it still
exists but that's my theory on how we
did that this is what an accident yeah
there's no myspace you weren't you
weren't up yummy yeah it was
Facebook Brendan think so yeah doesn't
eat but but then we've had a couple
other videos go viral like the action
taco birth in a big hurry to take
starter it's there no we don't have any
metrics for how many views it actually
has because they weren't counting views
and kick start at that point but it was
shared on Facebook over 14,000 times so
people are sharing it on Facebook that
means 50 other people saw it right so we
don't know exactly what the
um it was a lot it was definitely
definitely viral so and how did that
happen that was because of all the media
taken that how that got passed around
and stuff so you weren't doing like sub
for sub and you know stuff that people
painstaking though I never open those
emails that we get up for so subscribe
for subscribe oh it's like a sort of a
simple thing and then men and you should
build your channel behind people comment
that work for you um not really yeah you
know it seems like it may help a little
but I win those mysteries yeah we'd love
to know so we could do it again yeah
that's really cool so what opportunities
came out of that and I got some really
good auditions um and I was probably it
right a couple a couple of pilot
auditions how's it yeah but that one
that was because big deal is we actually
didn't even have agency at Point so so
that was cool and it's just sort of
bragging rights to to talk about and
here's this thing that we did we keep
hearing these stories about how agents
and managers and producers look at more
more apt to look at YouTube these days
but we haven't we haven't found that we
haven't really found that to being at
the case so far but i will see you never
know who will stop stumble upon one day
we'll do people recognize you i haven't
a little bit i've had a couple but
mostly in industry sort of related
things where they've seen articles about
about the viral video or something like
that our friend Bonnie Gillespie wrote a
book self management for actors and
there's a section in there that talks
about it and she uses it as a make your
own seeing everyone sort of example a
lot so people who are familiar with her
column have seen that oh great people
have recognized me through that
you